sieben auf einen streich lieben
exoplaneten die im trap istvan system um
einen stern kreisen das ist eine
wirkliche sensation und das besondere
daran jetzt in science fiction ist
herzlich willkommen
das ist musik seitigen wwf-report ihn
jetzt auf spitze operation so beschrieb
john kerry manager des schweizer science
center der nasa in pasadena die gestern
vorgestellte entdeckung mit ist also die
aufregendste entdeckung weiter spitzer
weltraumteleskop den weltraum beobachtet
gestern um 19 uhr deutscher zeit wurden
der weltöffentlichkeit wahre sensation
entdeckung präsentiert werden mitte 2016
noch von einem leben freundlichen drei
sterne system und dem planeten kempis
wand sprach sprechen die forscher jetzt
sogar schon von insgesamt sieben in
einer entfernung von ungefähr 40
lichtjahre von uns liegenden exoplaneten
oder sensationelle drei davon liegen in
der habitablen zone dort ist es weder zu
heiß noch zu kalt in diesem bereich
könnte tatsächlich leben geben
das alleine wäre noch nicht sensationell
für die forscher ist diese entdeckung
ein entscheidender schritt auf dem weg
zur entdeckung von außerirdischem leben
nicht nur auf diesen drei exoplaneten
sind alle ähnlich groß wie die erde
leben entdeckt werden könnte diese
entdeckung ist so bahnbrechend weil sie
bedeutet dass unser weltall wirklich von
erdähnlichen exoplaneten nur so voll ist
auf denen es eben leben geben könnte
wenn in unserer nähe schon so viele
exoplaneten existieren wie sieht es dann
erst im gesamten universum aus es müsste
eben voll davon seien und es müsste auch
voller leben sein und es könnte sogar
sein dass das leben auf aktuellen durch
das all reis und auf sämtlichen
exoplaneten in den habitablen zonen
seine saat hinterlässt gerade haben nasa
astrobiologin mikroorganismen die auf
der erde bisher unbekannt waren in
kristallen entdeckt wie waren zehn- bis
60.000 jahre eingeschlossen wenn ihr
mehr dazu erfahren wollt schreibt es in
die kommentare
dann mache ich ein video dazu jedenfalls
auf diese weise könnte leben von einem
zum anderen planeten reisen quasi base
weltraum spermien das apple system ist
nur 40 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt und kann ganz gut erforscht
werden das geld weg weltraumteleskop
staffel die am jahr 2018 und es wird das
tracking system untersuchen um es in den
worten von michael kilian von der
universität lädt zu sagen wir erkunden
ein anderes sonnensystem kleiner aber
dennoch bedeuten dass fekter skepsis
wann system wirklich im gegensatz zu
unserem sonnensystem um einiges länger
erhalten während unsere sonne nur noch
ein paar milliarden jahre unserem system
energie geben wird hält der stern im tab
ist wandels leben noch einige millionen
ja ich bin schwer beeindruckt und freue
mich auf eure meinung zum thema in den
kommentaren
er drückt mir noch schnell ein hier aber
aufs auge gibt noch einen auf die glocke
das möchten da sicher einige nach dem
titel von gestern
sorry for that und vier geht es zu dem
betreffenden video von gestern also bis
dann